[Music]
abraham is up in fort collins colorado
abraham how can we help
hey ken and rachel thanks for taking my
call sure um
so i'm a recent ramsay fan just this
summer
my wife and i have three kids and we
kind of made it to baby step two and
totally stalled out
we are way upside down as far as how
much house we have and trying to get to
the next best step to extricate and and
keep moving forward
tell us about the house um
so we bought our first starter house six
years ago for 2 30 and sold it for 315
so we did really well there bought our
next home
for 439 and sold it for 4.95 two years
later
we like to fix and flip
then we got our dream property here in
colorado with land and a home
but it was 680
so we we made it i actually did a no-no
and pulled out my 401k during covid with
no penalties and put that enough to get
the down payment
it is now
about 48 of our income is our house
payment
yeah and we've been here two years and
it's it's a struggle and obviously we're
not we're not investing we're not doing
anything else but living so
um the good news is we don't have we
have about three grand in credit card
debt that is it no other student loans
or other credit debt okay my question is
i know we need to probably get out from
under this
we could sell quickly and probably
get about 8.50
what we have remaining is 577 on the
house
or we could continue to do a little bit
more remodeling
maybe go into a little credit card debt
and hopefully get around 9 to 9 50 next
spring
i don't know well here's the only
question i have as tight as everything
is where are you going to get that
income
outside of the credit card that means
you're maxing out credit cards just to
be able to make these changes what
what's your combined income is it just
you working
what's your income situation
yeah my wife and i work i make about 105
a year and she makes about 20. she works
really part-time so we're about 125.
um
i buy my dream truck and oh i'm in uh
sales so i'm a sales territory sales
manager okay
what were you saying about your dream
truck
i did all the wrong things i think along
this process when we were in our last
home i bought my dream truck brand new
so that's three years old
that truck payment is about 500 a month
uh
what's that worth
uh i owe
about
33 on it and it's worth over 40. okay so
you do have other debt you said you just
had the credit cards so
yeah that is true okay yeah so the truck
is gonna go yeah what's the other car or
what's it do what's your other loan on
the car on the other car um
the other car we own is paid off it's
paid off
no like personal loans no 401 k loans i
know you cashed it out to do i'm just
making sure nothing else okay
so yeah
the truck and the
yes
so here's what's so
um
not fascinating it's probably the wrong
word abraham to use but
our homes you know people go into a home
um and like you said it's our dream home
and it sounds amazing right you get land
in colorado you get a home all of it
like it's it is a it's a sacred place to
people because it's where your kids are
it's where your family is i mean your
home is just such a cherished place
and what ends up happening is this thing
that we thought was such a blessing ends
up being the absolute biggest burden to
you and your wife like
i could imagine you are you're stressed
out you're thinking about it all the
time
when you want to go do something fun
it's like we have no money too i mean
it's just it is a constant
sore spot in your life and so this thing
that you thought was going to be such a
cherished wonderful
dreamy
part of your life ends up being this
burden and so that happens to so many
people abraham like that that's not a
shameful thing to say to you but that's
the reality and where a lot of people
are
um so yeah if i were you guys how old
are your kids
uh they're ten eight and four okay yeah
so you got little ones so
i mean so if i if i'm you i am relieving
as much stress as possible in my life
and doing renovations going into debt
for renovations all that adds way more
stress because stuff takes longer than
you expect it's always more expensive
and you're going to use debt which is
not even going to be an option that
we're going to give you so
um if i were you abraham i would i and i
know it hurts but i would i would sell
and i would find i would find a home
that you guys go back to that it's like
okay it's you know it's reasonably 25 of
our take-home pay
uh you sell the truck you pay off this
debt you guys get an emergency fund you
get back on solid footing and something
else happens too during this process
there's a level of realizing
man our priorities have just shifted i
would rather be in a smaller space with
peace of mind and i'm not losing sleep
at night than to have what i thought i
wanted and be stressed out and so
i would i would sell and i would i would
find something that you guys can afford
and and then the great thing too abraham
is you could look up in a few years and
and go get land again it's not like that
this is the only time you never could
or that you can uh in that truck you can
always go buy that truck again in a few
years your dream truck like all of this
whole thing of
being debt-free and getting a firm
foundation doesn't mean you can never
enjoy stuff or go back to the dreams
that you had you can always go back to
them but you're going to do it where
those dreams
are are a blessing it's a gift in your
life it doesn't take away from your life
and so what's happened is um is it's
been hard for you guys i can only
imagine so
um i hate to say sell it because i know
it's a dream of you guys to have lands
in a house but it's just it's and i
don't see your income going up or her
going back i wouldn't i wouldn't send
her back to work full-time unless she
wanted to to pay for a house payment
like i would not yeah i agree with you
it's not worth it it's just not worth it
well you bet but you gotta get rid of
the truck and the credit card in this
whole deal all right so like this is an
all-in get rid of all of it so you know
you're gonna have what seven grand and
some change left if you sell the truck
and you can get a decent older suv for
that that's just what you're gonna have
to do
you know well the blessing can is
actually my my job came with a company
vehicle so i don't actually need to
replace my truck so that's a really good
thing okay so now okay so now we take
the profit from the truck and we wipe
out the credit cards if i remember that
amount correctly
so now okay
yeah so let's just play some real fun
math here how much is that going to free
up in your budget
if we pay off the truck today and the
credit cards today what's the we got 500
a month on the truck what's on the
credit card right now minimum payments
uh minimum payments on the card are
about 80 bucks all right so okay 580
bucks but that's 580 bucks that's over
six thousand dollars a year
immediately yep you sell the house and
here's the thing i want you to hear and
dave's a great example usually this huge
dave ramsey's example so dave was in
real estate he was doing very well right
if you don't know dave's story the bank
called all the notes rachel's a baby you
know and he loses everything right but
dave went back got into real estate
even bigger than ever and it's all cash
so you all have experience see dave had
experience and i've heard him say to me
before he's like it's easier to make the
second million than it was the first
and you all have some knowledge you
flipped i think you said two houses
prior to this one so rachel made a very
good point i want to drive that home
yes this is a bit of a contraction
but it's temporary and now you're going
to come out of this be completely debt
free
no stress on mama you the three kids and
then you can start that flipping process
if you want to get back into that one
day but this time you do it all cash
because you know how to do it you've
been there before so i just want you to
be encouraged
in the midst of this pain because this
is painful
and i just want to acknowledge that this
is going to suck to sell this house
you know it is it feels like a step back
which is hard for me but yes i
understand it well let's be let's be
honest it is a step back but it will
position you to make so many more steps
forward faster yeah that's the key you
got to remember that right now because
it is a step back don't try to sugarcoat
it but it's going to position you and
you're going to come back better
and stronger than before and you're you
guys are functioning in such a tight
budget already that when you free it up
even moving homes your priorities may
shift you may realize huh what other
options do we have we talked about
options earlier so abraham you're a
great dad great husband and i think you
guys are making some hard decisions but
in in
nine months after everything's cleared
and done you're gonna breathe again and
sleep at night